what's going on everybody welcome to
another Django tutorial in this tutorial
what we're going to be talking about is
how to get your server to be secured
over HTTPS so the first thing you want
to do is head over to HTTPS let's
encrypt org and coded technology and
then how it works and we'll come down
here and these three lines are at least
the start for you to get HTTPS the first
thing you'll probably need to do though
is I'm gonna move this over is go ahead
and do suit apt-get update you don't
have to do sudo if your route I if you
see me type sudo even though I'm root
it's just because I'm not actually used
to being the root user usually you make
a new user and all that anyway so
apt-get update and then you'll need to
do have to get install get I've already
got it so that's okay but if you
followed along you probably don't have
it already
the next thing that we're going to do is
let's change directory into slash home
slash Django slash Django project and I
already have it but what you want to do
is you'll come over to let's encrypt org
and I'm just going to be copying and
pasting these three lines okay so the
first line I'm just copy come over here
paste I already have it so it's not
going to add anything next line
copy paste I mean that directory now and
then the third line copy paste and now
that's let's encrypt otto has been done
the next thing I'm just coming over here
while that's doing stuff in the
background is we're coming down and we
are actually because we're not using
apache russian using nginx it's going to
be a little different but what you'll
want to do is you'll basically run this
here replacing example comm with with
your website so I'm going to come down
here and the first thing we have to you
would have to do is service nginx stop
and then we're gonna I'm going to right
click that line and then instead of
example.com
mine is cyber I oh now again I've
already done this so I'm not going to
have to really do
anything more but basically what this is
going to do is it just gives you this
certificate for HTTP so yours would be a
little different but like for example I
can renew and replace the certificate
and it should take me through the exact
same stuff that it would do for you so
we'll see if that works okay
well that's already done but it should
ask you for your email address so so put
in your email address then basically you
should have something that looks a
little bit like this so once that's done
you have to set up nginx to actually use
HTTPS because even though we have the
certificate if we go to you know cyber
io it's not going to be secured over
HTTPS it's not going to be actually
using HTTPS or certificate so anyways
what we need to do now is go sudo nano
slash etc' slash engine oops nginx slash
sites available slash Jango hit enter
and you should have this you've seen
this already because we came down here
remember for the static files anyway
going up to the top we're going to
comment out listening on port 80 that's
just regular HTTP and then we're going
to comment out the listening on some
more listen on port 80 stuff now what
we're going to add is let's see work so
we come out those lines and then what we
want to go ahead and add here is a few
things first of all we want to listen on
443 which is your SSL port and then
there's basically three lines here I'm
going to go ahead and I'm gonna copy
this if you go to Python program in
Anette I'll put a link in the
description for these lines I don't want
to have to type them all out
and then you can copy and paste these
lines so I'm going to paste and
smooth this over so if you recall mine
was just simply cyber die oh so you're
replacing example calm with whatever
your website is so mine would be cyber
IO and then this just make sure they're
on the scene over here and then replace
this example comm with whatever your
website is bio and then again whoops
cyber die oh so that basically will tell
um tell your server to be using SSL okay
sorry hit the wrong button anyway
control X out well let's just check this
one more time actually we're gonna stay
in this file don't control X if you did
go back in here come on down this is in
the main server part what we want to do
is what we want to do also is redirect
HTTP to HTTPS so let me come up here so
this is this is all that an initial
server block right so you've got the
curly brace there and then coming down
this curly brace is corresponding to
location this is corresponding the
original server we're going to add one
more thing which is going to be server
to curly braces and then what we want to
add here just for spaces
listen 80 and then server underscore
name is cyber i/o and then return 301
which is a redirect to HTTPS colon slash
slash dolla sign post dolla sign request
underscore URI okay so what that's doing
is it's just redirecting basically any
request that's made to cyber do with any
request URI which is basically stuff
after your domain name and it just
redirects them to HTTPS version of that
coming down now can
x2 say yes enter and then what you want
to do is nginx should be actually off
but we'll go ahead and do a service
nginx restart so now if we go to cyber I
oh when we go to ok something went wrong
here but let's try HTTP colon slash
slash ok so you'll see HTTP colon slash
slash cyber auto works we can navigate a
boot ok so let me go back over to our
redirect for some reason our redirect is
not working let's go down what did what
did you guys forget maybe the semicolon
here let's add that X yes to save go
ahead and restart nginx and come back
over and let's go to still ok uh so my I
think mine just hasn't there we go
alright so if you go now to type cyber I
owe you or your domain you should be
there if if for whatever reason you're
still returning that old nginx
nonsense hold shift f5 in Chrome and
that's like a hard refresh so it's not
your cuz before you're probably getting
a cache anyway boom HTTP awesome I love
let's encrypt I'm not sure if you guys
saw it eh still here once you install
your certificate there's a nice let's
encrypt org slash donate URL highly
suggest you maybe pop them over five
dollars or something
anyways so that's it that's HTTP for you
guys if you have any questions comments
concerns whatever feel free to leave
them below
again this is HTTP for nginx with our
one-click install via Jango that we've
done so if you're using a different
servers especially like Apache
that this is not the process for you so
just keep that in mind
anyways questions comments leaving below
otherwise as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support subscriptions
and until next time